l'alarmé intrusion s'est déclenché à 2
heures ce matin puis le feu a ravagé les
fragiles containers qui abritait la
maison du projet d'éco quartier des
vennes à la fois espace de présentation
et de commercialisation des futurs
logements
un incendie qui ressemble à une mauvaise
nouvelle pour le maire confronté à une
opposition récurrentes sur ce projet je
suis atterré
cette maison c'est la maison du dialogue
c'est un lieu de rencontre on vient ici
pour exposer ses besoins pour discuter
d'un projet et éventuellement le faire
amender et on a voulu tuer le dialogue
donc c'est très très grave
dans ce quartier bisontin peu habitués
aux feux de poubelles les opposants ont
bien du mal à imaginer un acte de
rébellion extrême de l'un des leurs même
si ce chantier d'urbanisation de plus de
24 hectares fait polémique depuis 2005
nous on conteste ce projet mais dans des
formes démocratiques c'est bien évident
qu'on qu'on donne complètement ce genre
d'actes nous on est sur des pétitions de
l' échange d'arguments de la
mobilisation citoyenne et associative
donc on n'est pas du tout la suite ici
center qui a toujours été maraîchère
qu'erich québec est riche de jardin
qu'erich de biodiversité avec des
espèces protégées
donc en fait on conteste le fait de
d'artificialité ce soldat qui perd riche
avec le changement climatique à venir on
va avoir besoin de ses poumons verts de
ces espaces verts et de ses terres
riches naturellement humide
l' enquête a été confiée à la police
criminelle et la municipalité s'est
engagée reconstruire au plus vite le
préfet de son côté a décidé de suspendre
les travaux en cours afin de réexaminer
le volet environnemental et mieux
accompagner le projet un nouvel arrêté
devrait être promulguée dans un délai
d'un mois